wait wait easy there buddy
there's my crab anyone's gonna be
[ __ ] with my crab it's me
gonna be me oh you almost spilled my
crab juice i wasn't even gonna bring the
whole thing
is anybody out there gonna donate some
more hair grafts to matt cox
or arm extensions or arm extensions or a
neck extension
well they have a light bulb in there the
light bulb we need to wet back the neck
we gotta get
a second neck double neck
he needs two necks
[Laughter]
what about a dick implant has he have
you guys touched on that at all
um i don't think anybody's talking about
that yet we should ask him about that
when he gets back
is that a possibility oh yeah there's a
there's multiple documentaries about
that on youtube i've seen
multiple i've already looked into it
i've never already done a bunch of calls
i've never searched it don't worry about
it yeah i'm
not that i'm interested it just kind of
popped up in my feed yeah that's just
spicy as hell
yeah it's crispy crab you never had the
crispy crab cross beef crab
that's what i ordered on my birthday
because we gotta
grab at gam's house where's the crispy
crab oh [ __ ] you just got some crab
like juice on my headphones you just got
three dollars to do another deckhand
oh really that'll cover it wow
thank you jamie walker much three bucks
to do jack
jack hands that'll cover a pack of 305s
for shane lee that doesn't even
cover shane's lead beers tab you have no
idea how expensive it is to have shane
lee for the day
no it's expensive are you eating this
isn't the show
no i i don't know i told you he's eating
the bones matt the bones
i need the bone there's no that's their
mouth how do you spit this shell out
have you ever considered getting crab
before you broke these
have you ever considered getting a penis
implant um
uh how much would that cost i don't know
i haven't looked into that although
is anybody in the live chat i'm sure i
should no
anyone no
um subscribe to matt cox inside true
crime on youtube
buy his book on the run
with the secret service most wanted con
artist with a fine arts degree matt cox
oh my god
[ __ ] i can't think of anything else but
you eating that crab
i know me neither i was fire
it just looks like you know what a huge
bug leg
like it's starship troopers like they i
love that movie it's a great movie
it's great really yeah you fine arts
[ __ ] you love starship troopers are you
serious you never saw it that's a plaza
no
i'm glad we could agree yeah finally
what kind of music do you listen to matt
cox um
country music really only country pretty
much what kind of country like
hank williams jr no like like kit moore
um i don't know who that is okay uh
kenny chesney yeah the pop country [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah what's your favorite movie of all
time
[Laughter]
it's uh i would say why is that funny
because the way he asked it
um the crab legs be hitting they hit
different
did you ever see gattica yeah
gattica and probably shawshank shawshank
really shawshank was good yeah
that's a cool just because i never
because i remember watching it and just
never saw the ending coming yeah i was
just like wow
didn't you uh name some of the like the
names after reservoir dogs or something
like that yeah yeah the the
the scam i was running the farming
scheme mr brown mr p
yeah yeah it was uh that was
james red brandon green david silver
michael white lee black william blue
and somebody asked you about that right
they thought it was funny or something i
thought you told them the story
i've told you nobody ever caught you on
it no they
no it never came well keep in mind they
were they were all separate loans
separate places it was just never
overlapping
oh yeah yeah yeah i got you when i got
caught by the bank
i got caught by the bank i don't know
maybe yeah i was on the phone and the
guy
was trying to explain to him how i got
the appraisals jacked up
yeah hey is waffle house open i'm hungry
still
aren't they 24 7. yeah that's candy in
there can you [ __ ] you're
going to be driving through
they need to open my goddamn [ __ ] up
open up get us back to work
this is my constitutional right to go
outside and be close to other people and
sit in waffle house
i need my scared of the coronavirus
i want to say no because i almost never
leave like i just say home and paint
but i i do notice that when i go out i'm
hypervision and [ __ ] yeah
it's it gets weird and i'm like so i
find myself
being conscience conscious not to touch
my face
not to do things but you know which and
then i touch my face but
um you know like you push the door
handle open with your thing and you're
listening to that
stacy has like clients that won't leave
the house like they're like i'm not
leaving
she had one client that told her um
she's like okay i think you're being a
little bit stacy is your landlord right
yeah
and my a friend of mine yeah and she
goes she's like i feel like you're being
going over the top and the woman told
her she said
she just i didn't feel comfortable
talking to you on the phone right now
what
yeah she was like and she was that's how
nuts she was wow i'm not
i haven't left my house in over a month
i this i that i order everything
i wash everything i said what are you
doing you're [ __ ] crazy here i mean
you know
i don't know listen the economy what
it's doing to the economy i mean this is
just
devastating it's just ridiculous yeah i
mean honestly to be honest
couldn't we just let it run its course i
mean granted you're gonna lose a chunk
of people
some people actually think that this
whole thing is made up
to ruin donald trump that's crazy that
some people actually think that
bro i mean it's not that crazy i mean
maybe that is
true bro that is absolutely not true it
could be true
trump just cut me a check for 1200 bucks
i mean i know it's [ __ ] crazy it
seems crazy out there in the universe
and we think that it's completely
[ __ ]
absurd to think that but all this aside
what if there was actually some people
out there who [ __ ]
made all this [ __ ] up or created every
actually released the virus just to [ __ ]
donald trump up for some political
[ __ ] up reasons who could generate
that sounds
serious truth bombs
you should change your first name to
alex
because you are really his son
really blowing up the internet i'm kind
of [ __ ] okay
the worst thing for donald trump is
donald trump and the only thing that's
going to prevent him from doing
anything is himself yeah totally
totally i totally agree with you but
sometimes i [ __ ] get really high and
i think about like
what i just have this feeling what if
what if all this crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] the
crazy people were talking about it's
easy to ask questions
then how do you feel yeah but if you are
right
and then you have to actually explain
your thoughts have you ever heard
now what do you do now how do you feel
what do you say now
yeah have you ever heard sean atwood
explain his conspiracy theories
about like 911 and the clinton [ __ ] like
some of that [ __ ] seems so outlandish
and bizarre
but it's not that far fetched but it
once he like lays out all the facts it's
true i mean
maybe somewhere down the road there will
be somebody like that who
actually goes in and finds out all the
secrets
and actually proves that this was some
big conspiracy theory
conspiracy theories are like a nice like
alternate reality it's like fan fiction
for things that are actually happening
it's easy to like ask questions
and make up stories about what you think
actually happened
but what's actually i mean nothing's
ever a conspiracy
i think honestly that ever nobody has
any idea and things just happen
and we're just reacting to it and nobody
can make simulations no no nobody can
just accept that things happen and there
has to always be some like huge story
behind that that's controlled
yeah it's like oh somebody's controlling
it's like things just happened
to be crazy one way or three yeah but
it's really hard to just accept that
people [ __ ] up things slip through the
cracks and [ __ ] happens but
everything's random
yeah danny you just keep asking
questions like that have nothing to back
it up and then say yeah but you know
like sometimes should be like weird what
about jeffrey epstein what do you think
what do you think about jeffrey epstein
do you think he killed himself
who knows
that one i will [ __ ] get on board
with that one that's too convenient
[Music]
there's no conspiracies with el chapo oh
[ __ ] i'll get on board with that i'll
get on that one i get on that one what
do you think of epstein
matt absolutely we already asked him he
had this guy yeah i know but let's go
matt doesn't know look there's people
matt's a guy who looks good assume he's
got a lot of plastic surgery
he's really confident and he tells that
he's got a good story okay
okay everyone everyone is subscribed to
the match
anything you say really thinking himself
why i mean because he had a he had
he had a ton of money you don't think he
could have bought his way out of his
situation
no listen he would have never let it get
that far too much leverage
first of all it was too high profile
he's in prison
he he hung himself the going from the
level he was there
somebody killed him huh you don't think
he was going to squeal tell the news on
everybody
listen listen and they killed him to get
into a prison and kill someone
is virtually impossible not to have the
guards dude right the car the guards
aren't gonna
there's too many guards there's two and
you really think he hung himself
yeah you don't think you think it's
impossible for that to happen for them
to kill him inside there
didn't you say too many cameras there's
too many there's too many people would
have
been involved i have a question why did
the cameras go bad
that's a question half the cameras don't
work anyway well what the f
well that's a convenient experience
tons of the camera's just done that's
where my time went to bad cameras
yeah bad cameras that's underneath bad
cameras and you're going to so you're
going to go get
some guard but they'll catch me using
bank fraud i bet that
some guard making 60 70 000 a year i'm
gonna how do
i even approach you to say hey look i
know we're gonna you're gonna be on
epstein's [ __ ] thing
and we're gonna get you and that other
guard billy bob
and we're talking to billy bob and we're
about you guys to go in
and kill epstein that's never gonna
happen never
no it could happen no they're going to
listen they're going to be jammed
and then we kill you then they're going
to kill you
and then everything just disappears
afterwards and the cameras are bad
there's no case
there's no talk of it he he dies
disappears everybody's going why did he
do that why would he kill himself
wait who's got something to gain from me
he's killed himself i don't know maybe
somebody killed him this [ __ ]
these people are betty ain't eating no
snow crab right now yeah he guaranteed
and you know snow crab
let's wrap this [ __ ] up what are we
doing here have you are you reading the
card this is just
ridiculous i got a little epstein
wormhole matt why don't you read one
oh somebody thinks i positive epstein
died from autoerotic asphyxiation he
finished
before he died though what about this is
that the
that's good to know the recent